okay interesting little update for you
on the Trump Russia story and of course
remember that all along we have had a
series of moving goal posts a sliding
scale of denials about how there was
never any contact with Russians by the
Trump administration well maybe there
was contact but there was certainly no
coordination well even if we coordinated
it certainly wasn't collusion and hey
you know what even if there was
collusion collusion in and of itself
isn't illegal one of the data points of
that coordination was that Trump Tower
meeting with lawyer Russian lawyer
Natalia vessel Mnet's kaya and we were
told nothing came of it we were told
that it was a bogus meeting that there
was no follow-up and then we realized
actually there was follow-up and then we
realized actually that was the meeting
at which this quid pro quo was intimated
where if the Trump campaign ends up
receiving dirt on Hillary from the
Russians and they end up winning they
would be willing potentially to ease
Russian sanctions that's what we call a
quid pro quo and now it turns out that
not only was there follow-up and not
only was there a quid pro quo intimated
to Natalia vessel its kaya she was in
Washington DC for Donald Trump's
inauguration and attended an
inauguration party one year ago and in
fact the Washington Post has a great
piece on the many notable Russians who
were very weirdly in DC for the
inauguration so many Russians were in DC
for the inauguration in fact that the
intelligence community took notice and
expressed concern the FBI was concerned
because some of the same people that
surfaced when they were investigating
possible Trump campaign connections to
Russia some of those same people were in
Washington DC for the inauguration
wealthy Russian pharmaceutical executive
Alexei repick got close enough to Trump
to shake hands with him at a pre
inauguration event he was seated with
his wife right in front of the Capitol
building for the swearing-in he took a
picture with now CIA director Mike
Pompeo Viktor Vekselberg is a tycoon
who's closely aligned with the Putin
government he was in DC for the
inauguration
Boris T Tov a politician and business
advocate now running for president of
Russia with the blessing of the Kremlin
was there and Natalia vessel Mnet's kaya
the Russian lawyer from the now infamous
Trump Tower meeting was at the
inauguration and who at an inauguration
party and who invited her the one
congressman who we've heard time and
again is a Russian puppet republican
dana rohrabacher and along with natalia
vessel mats kaya renato ahmed chin was
at the same inauguration party with
natalia vessel Mnet's kaya they both
happen to have been at that total
nothing bird or Trump Tower meeting the
random person
Natalia vessel Mnet's kaya who brought
nothing to the Trump administration and
had nothing to do with anything
happened to be in Washington DC when
Donald Trump was being inaugurated just
months after she showed up at Trump
Tower to give them dirt on Hillary
Clinton in exchange for the possible
easing of Russian sanctions it's just a
coincidence Pat why is anybody worried
about this stuff well I think it makes
sense that a presidential inauguration
you not only have like congressmen and
Senators there you also have the people
who helped you win right your campaign
staff and again the audience we're gonna
have Russians in this scenario that's
the most simple explanation but it's the
one that the Trump team is going to be
increasingly apoplectic in order over in
order to try to deny so I tried to go
back and and find are there any so we've
we've identified a lot of statements
that they claimed to were true which are
definitely lies maybe when Sean Spicer
said at Donald Trump's direction that
this was the largest crowd ever for an
inauguration maybe what he should have
said is this was the largest crowd of
Russians ever to attend a president's
inauguration in Washington DC and then
that statement made hours after the
inauguration would have been true right
am i digging a little too deep here I'm
a silver lining I'm just thinking that
because he said that it was the largest
attended inauguration in presidential
history I mean that means that people
were poor again from all around the
world and not only did you have Russians
you had Ukrainians and people from
Belarus and
Latvia some of whom I assume are good
people yes I really hope that Robert
Muller gets to the bottom of all of this
because there are just too many of these
so-called coincidences at this point for
them to really be coincidences the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad